alexis 1 le malaise dans la police
persiste un on le constate une
manifestation est attendue demain on l'a
dit le ras-le-bol très persistant chez
ces forces de l'ordre déjà pour quelle
raison le ras-le-bol ils sont en parle
d'argenteuil
aujourd'hui c'est toutes les semaines à
peu près que la police ait pris pour
cible dans des guets-apens avec les
pompiers souvent lorsqu'ils sont en
intervention c'est le fait d'être
également pris pour cible par la menace
terroriste les terroristes islamiques
qui ont décidé de frapper simplement les
gens en uniforme
on se rappelle bien sûr c'était au plus
près de nous le commissariat de
rambouillet en deuil et et puis le fait
qu' ils sont aussi mal aimés d'une
partie de la population parce qu'il faut
le sale boulot ils sont utilisés d'une
façon politique pour aller au clash avec
les manifestants plutôt que de protéger
les manifestants
il ya un problème aussi par rapport à la
façon dont l'ordre est organisée tout ça
fait qu'à un moment les policiers ont
effectivement ras-le-bol d'être
maltraités mal jugé mal vus par leurs
ministères mal encadrée et ce ras-le-bol
il n'est pas neuf c'est à dire qu'on a
l'impression de voir quelque chose de
nouveau mais il n'a fait que monter ces
dernières années parce que il ya eu je
pense à un moment clé qui a été une
faille
rappelez-vous en 2005 quand on a eu
l'embrasement des banlieues les
l'élection de nicolas sarkozy en 2007
s'était fait un peu là dessus il était
ministre de l'intérieur à l'époque il
avait dit qu'il allait changer tout ça
et qu'est ce qu'il fait à ce moment là
et bien il réduit le nombre de postes de
fonctionnaires de police et il impose la
politique du chiffre la politique du
résultat qui fait que les policiers
n'étaient plus finalement dans
l'encadrement ou dans une politique
humaniste du maintien de l'ordre d'une
police républicaine mais une police du
chiffre et si ça fait aujourd'hui des
policiers en mal être avec
un nombre de suicides important dans
cette profession est une violence
permanente puisque c'est un métier qui
se confrontent quotidiennement à la
violence donc le ras-le-bol
il est compréhensible et malheureusement
je crois que les réponses de ce
gouvernement n'ont pas été à la hauteur
ces derniers mois alexi gérald darmanin
qui a donc annoncé manifester aux côtés
des syndicats beaucoup se demandent si
c'est vraiment la place d'un ministre de
l'intérieur c'est quand même assez
inédit c'est même cocasse que voir que
le ministre qui est mis en cause par les
syndicats manifestent finalement avec
les syndicats montrent la position de
faiblesse de ce ministre par rapport à
la force des syndicats de police
d'ailleurs le syndicat de police des
commissaires par la voix de son
secrétaire général
la ville de barr a dit clairement que
les politiques qui ne passe ici se prête
pas à cette manifestation devrait en
payer le prix
ou quelque chose qui s'approchait de
cette formule disant que tous les
politiques devraient être solidaires
derrière les policiers et d'ailleurs
fabien roussel du parti communiste
français a dit qu'il serait lui il
présente demain parce que la sécurité
est un thème important dans les
quartiers pour les classes les plus
populaires et c'est vrai que cette
sécurité elle a été abandonnée par de
nombreux responsables politiques de
gauche qui pensaient que elle n'était
pas de leur ressort ou que ça
n'apportait pas assez de voir la
sécurité n'a pas de couleur politique
elle est même l'équivalent de la liberté
liberté et sécurité
il faut faire en sorte que les gens
vivent dans la concorde et sans avoir
peur quand ils sortent de chez eux et ça
ça n'a pas de couleur politique donc les
syndicats en sont très conscients ils
voient bien que les temps ont changé et
que après finalement le moment deux
d'entre deux où les populations ont été
plutôt peureuse dégoûté face à de
nombreuses violences policières lors des
manifestations du gilet jaune par
exemple les temps ont changé avec les
attentats avec le fait aussi qu'il est
nécessaire d'avoir une police
républicaine qui assurent la sécurité de
tous
donc ils en profitent et disent que
maintenant les politiques doivent être
avec eux ou pas mais qu'un ministre
participe à une manifestation
là par contre c'est vraiment du racolage
et on est dans quelque chose
d'exceptionnel parce que le ministre il
est là pour
répondre de ses actions pour donner des
moyens mais certainement pas pour
manifester avec les manifestants ça
s'est jamais vu alors depuis un très bon
saut ça remonte tout de même quelques
ministres de l'intérieur on suit
incarner la fonction à la hauteur de
l'état at on perdu tout sens du régalien
en france avec ce gouvernement
oui c'est ce qui pose question c'est à
dire que quand on a un ministre de
l'intérieur qui finalement manifeste
c'est ubuesque
ou alors ce héros lien mais ça n'a rien
à voir avec la force régaliennes
l'autorité de l'état qui est rabâché
d'ailleurs à à longueur de plateau en
disant il faut le retour de l'autorité
mais 70 manifestants avec des syndicats
policiers qu'on va remettre l'autorité
au coeur de l'état on a l'impression que
cette fonction s'est délité avec le
temps vous parliez de clemenceau qui
était à un ministre de l'intérieur
iconique qu'il y en ait d'autres
tout le monde se rappelle de charles
pasqua ce qu'il a fait aussi à
l'intérieur était particulier c'est une
fonction difficile puisqu'on doit
assurer l'ordre mais aussi assurer les
élections assuré aussi l'organisation de
la laïcité à la française ce qui est une
exception internationale
donc c'est vraiment une charge très
lourde sur les épaules d'une seule
personne manuel valls qui étaient
remises de l'intérieur peut-être trop
ambitieux qui voulait lui très vite
monter les échelons et souvent un
ministre de l'intérieur c'est quelqu'un
qui a en tête un avenir politique
rappelez-vous et nicolas sarkozy il est
longtemps ministre l'intérieur et il
prépare sa campagne pour devenir
président c'était en 2007 c'est pour ça
que je vous parle un peu de ce hiatus
par rapport à ce qu'il s'est passé dans
les banlieues on a eu ensuite
aujourd'hui gérald darmanin qui est
finalement le fils spirituel ou c'est
ainsi qu'il aimerait se positionner de
nicolas sarkozy mais qui certainement né
n'est pas à la hauteur compte tenu de
cette déclaration de vouloir manifester
avec les manifestants quand on est
ministre on ne manifeste pas on répond
aux revendications des syndicats mais
certainement pas ça et c'est la preuve
que ce gouvernement ne comprends pas
quel est le rôle d'un gouvernement c'est
d'assurer l'autorité de l'état
les fonctions régaliennes et aujourd'hui
on est dans la communication à tout va
dans le clientélisme à tout va et c'est
inquiétant et pour l'état et pour les
citoyens français qui se demande
finalement s'il sont gouvernés ou si ils
ont affaire à un personnel politique en
campagne permanente et on a l'impression
qu'aujourd'hui
et bien ça y est la campagne
présidentielle ayant commencé c'est la
campagne permanente et il n'y a plus de
ministre ni de pilote dans l'avion
tout le monde est vent debout derrière
emmanuel macron pour le pousser vers sa
candidature pour 2022 merci beaucoup à
alexis poulain éditorialistes d'avoir
été en direct avec nous